[MUSIC PLAYING]
HELEN LO: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining
us here today.
I'm here with my
co-worker, Harry.
My name is Helen, and we're
both customer engineers
at Google Cloud.
So one of our jobs,
as customer engineers,
is to assist our customers
in growing their application
in Google Cloud.
Which tools and
which services would
fit their current solution?
So during this session, we
want to do a step by step
walk through of how to grow your
application from one user all
the way up to 100 million users,
and what is the best design
practice that we often see.
So feel free to ask any
questions on the Dory Q & A.
Harry and I will answer the
questions offline afterwards.
So we're going to
approach this session
in a more customer focused way.
I'll be acting as a
user of GCP, and Harry
will be my customer engineer.
He'll be assisting me as
I grow my application.
Imagine I'm currently
in a startup,
and I just built my
own e-commerce website,
and I have a handful
of engineers, handful
of employees, in my company.
So my first step
in my Cloud journey
is to deploy my application
to Google Cloud Platform,
and my first impression
of Google Cloud is this--
I have a bunch different
types of services.
You have compute,
storage, machine learning,
and in fact, there's actually
even more than what's
on this place right here.
So now my concern is,
which service do I pick?
Which one would work for
my current architecture?
Which one would I
need to consider
as my application grows?
So the second thing
that I looked up
is design architectures
on Google Cloud Platform,
and there are a few
that I found online.
Some of them might be
useful for my architecture,
but not so much
for the other ones.
So how do I take the
individual services
from the previous slide
and build my own solution
architecture that works for my
current solution, right now?
And what should I consider
as my application grows?
Many of you might be starting
out in Cloud just like I am
or many of you may have
hundreds of thousands
or even millions of users
on your application.
So the takeaway is
that, for all of you,
you should be able to understand
what kind of obstacles
we will face, and what is the
best design solution that we'll
see.
Let's break this session, or
my journey, into six stages--
starting with one user on
my web app, all the way up
to 100 million users--
and along each stage,
Harry will be assisting me
to troubleshoot
and problem solve
my current architectural issues.
So I'm beginning my journey
with just myself as a developer.
I recently created my
e-commerce website.
Think of this stage
as the alpha stage.
I'm inviting my
friends and customers
to try out my new
website, and everything
works on my development machine,
on my local environments.
So the next thing I want to
do is to deploy my application
in GCP.
So think of it as
just replicating
my local environment into a
VM in Google Cloud Platform.
One of the tools that
really assists me
in the first phase of my
deployment is Cloud Shell.
Think of it as a
dedicated VM instance that
is installed with all
of the Google Cloud
decay, some frameworks,
some language supports.
This allows me to
use the Command
line to manage
all of my services
in Google Cloud and
even deploy and develop
my code in Cloud Shell.
One way that I
often use it is if I
have my code in a repository
or in a VM in GCP.
What I can do is, I can clone
that into my Cloud Shell
and edit it through the built
in editor and then re-deploy
it right there in the Cloud
without using my development
machine.
So the reason I
use this a lot is
because I'm just starting
out my application,
as a developer, an IT Ops.
I'm heavily relying
on Cloud Shell
to manage my Cloud
resources and configurations
in my first few stages
of my application.
So when I say that I want to
deploy my application in GCP,
what I really mean
is that I want
to put my code and my services
in Google's infrastructure.
We have over 19 regions
around the globe,
and where we are
right now, we're
actually closest to
a Los Angeles region.
So I'm just starting
out my application,
and I want to deploy
to my region closest
to my customer, Los Angeles.
But of course, as my
application grows,
I will have customers
all over the world.
So I will be deploying
to multiple regions
in the near future.
This is a very
simple architecture
that we currently have now.
Think of it as I deployed a VM
instance in US-west2, the Los
Angeles region, and
within that region,
I've deployed my VM in
zone A. So with the least
amount of effort, I replicated
my local environment
to an environment in the Cloud.
It is currently running a web
server and a MySQL database.
The user can access this
solution through a domain name,
for example, mywebapp.com,
and the traffic
will be resolved at the
external IP attached to IBM.
Now the user can start
testing my application,
testing my alpha phase.
This is the simplest solution
on Google Cloud right now.
Think of it as the lift
and shift migration.
Now that we moved
into stage two,
and I have around 10K users, I'm
experiencing some odd behavior
and performance issues.
I can summarize that into
three types of issues.
The single one is
single instance failure.
Since I only have a
single VM and there
might be different
types of errors
that occur on that
single instance,
think of it as VM issues,
web service issues,
or database issues.
Whenever that happens, I need
to either restart my services
or reboot my VM.
What that really means
is that there is downtime
to my whole application.
This is the cause of a
single instance failure.
So another type of issue
is a single zone failure.
Imagine that my VM is hosted
in zone A of the Los Angeles
region.
For some unlikely reason
something happens to that zone,
and I don't have any backup
instances in another zone.
This will, again, cause my
whole application downtime.
And then finally,
scalability issues.
So as my application
grows, I have more users
concurrently accessing my
application, which might cause
some inconsistent behaviors.
That really can
be avoided since I
don't have any monitoring
or auto healing or anything
within my single VM right now.
So based on these
issues, we can observe
that my current architecture
is really flawed
with single point failure--
meaning one failure will
cause my whole application,
my whole system, to go down.
Based on all of that,
what I really need
is to build a scalable and
resilient web application.
Scalable simply means
that my application
needs to work with one
user all the way up to 100
million users.
Resilient means
that my application
needs to be highly available.
It needs to continue
to function when
an unexpected failure happens.
For example, if
the VM has issues
or if the zone
experiences failure,
my application needs to
remain fault tolerant.
Harry is going to give us some
ideas of how to do that in GCP.
HARRY LIN: OK.
Thanks, Helen.
It's good to see your business
grow to over 10,000 users.
This is the simple
architecture that Helen
is running on Google Cloud.
We start small,
and the provision,
only one single VM instance.
As the application grows,
the number of VM instances
grows as well.
So we can find that it
is getting difficult,
but still manageable.
Now, what if you need to scale
over tens of VM instances?
And when one of them goes
down, you have to take action.
Or when traffic
dips, you suddenly
have all of these
servers, which are idle.
So Managed Instance Group
comes into the solution
to assist with auto-scaling
and auto-healing instances.
Manage Instance Group contains
a single base instance template.
When the service needs to
scale out for new instance,
Manage Instance Group
can create a new instance
from this base template.
In addition, Manage Instance
Group has three major features.
The first one is autoscaler.
Autoscaler can create
and destroy VM instances
based on the loading, which
is defined by yourself.
For example, you can use the
network throughput, CPU usage,
and memory usage as
the scale in metric.
The second one is auto-healer.
Auto-healer will
recreate the instance
which becomes unhealthy.
Unhealthy can be also defined by
yourself with the custom health
check.
The third one is
regional distribution.
The regional
distribution-- you can
distribute all of
the VM instances
across the multiple zones which
makes your solution more highly
available.
Looking at these three
separate features,
these actually solve the
previous issues that we have--
scalability and
high availability.
With autoscaler we can make sure
that your application is always
scaling to the current zone.
With auto-healer and the
regional distribution
your application can
recreate unhealthy instances
and avoid single zone failure.
Now that we have Managed
Instance Group config,
we need to distribute your
traffic across all the VM
instances within the group.
This is where the were load
balancer comes into play.
Using the original
Managed instance Group,
we can deploy your instances
across multiple zones.
Load balancer will spread
the traffic across all the VM
instances within
the group, and there
is the single Anycast IP
attached to this network load
balancer.
So all of your users will
access this fixed Anycast IP
in order to access a fleet of
instances behind this Match
Instance Group.
Now our service
is scalable, able
to handle traffic and
unexpected outages,
but I'm sure that
many of you will
wonder how this staple
service is scalable.
Take database as an example.
In previous
architecture, you can
see that we run all of the
services on the same VM
instance.
This is half the scale
in point of view,
and also harmful to
service availability.
Imagine that one
instance is down
which costs the entire service
running on the same instance
to be down as well.
Hence, this is why
architecture evolves.
We decouple the application
into the typical three tier web
applications.
The frontend, the backend
and the third base layer.
Manage Instance Group is
configured to both frontend
and backend service to
provide scalability and high
availability.
At each layer, we deployed a VM
instance across multiple zones
to cope with the
single zone failure.
At the frontend we have
the Cloud load balancer
to distribute the
traffic to the frontend,
and we use the internal load
balancer to spread the traffic
to the backend service as we
deploy our backend service
into the private network.
And the third base layer--
MySQL is running on Compute
Engines with the HA mode.
This provides the master
to slave replication
for HA purposes,
and you re-replica
can be added manually to
improve the performance.
And don't forget the monitoring
and the logging which easily
helps you to troubleshoot
your system when something
goes wrong.
Stackdriver is a
comprehensive service
that helps you to
monitor and make
alert policies in
abnormal situations.
If you have auditing or
troubleshooting needs,
the Stackdriver's logging
and tracing abilities
are exactly for that.
In addition,
Stackdriver debugger
can help you to
debug your service
online without
interrupting your service.
So in this stage, we address
scalability and resilience
through the Manage Interest
Group and load balancer.
Application is also
decoupled into three tiers
to avoid interruption
between services.
Stackdriver is a
comprehensive service
to help you monitor,
debug, trace your system.
So I hope that is
helpful to design
your system at this phase.
Helen.
HELEN LO: Thanks, Harry.
So now that we have the
common three tier application,
my users have grown 100K, and we
actually run into a new issue.
So looking back at the
current design that we have,
everything is scalable
and highly resilient.
So going to 100K has
created a new issue
in my architecture--
specifically, the data layer.
So since MySQL database,
right now, is installed,
and I had to manually manage
it on VM in the Compute Engine.
So this is not a very
scalable solution.
As the number of users grow,
the number of concurrent users
grow at the same time.
So the number of
concurrent reads and writes
to my VMs will
increase, and this
is going to cause some
issues on my data layer.
There are a couple of
ways to improve this.
One, maybe I can
increase the disk
on my current VM which
will increase IOPS,
or another way is, I can add
another re-replica that Harry
mentioned, but this
a lot of overhead.
We have to install
VMs, manage the VMs,
and manage the SQL databases.
So I want to take it
as a Cloud approach.
So I can, maybe, leverage Google
Cloud's manage SQL services,
or another way is, if I
can offload my database
loading using Redis cache.
So back to the database issue.
There are many database services
on Google Cloud Platform
right now, and I'm not really
sure which one I should pick.
Which one will be useful
for my current situation?
Harry, what do you think?
HARRY LIN: OK.
Yeah, so database
and storage is one
of the most critical
missions when
you build out your service.
On Google Cloud there are many
services, storage and database
services, that you can adopt
based on your user cases
and scenarios.
Take database as an example.
You have a choice of Relational
database, NoSQL database,
and the Warehouse, as well.
If you have a typical
transaction to process,
the Relational database will
be a good choice for you.
Here, in our case, we will
focus on in-Memory database
and the Relational database
as we need to at this stage.
Look at the current
solution, we are running
MySQL on Compute Engine.
It has few areas
that we can improve.
We know that database engines
are a fast evolving technology.
So the new, major version
and the minor, past version
keeps coming to enforce the
database demonstrator operating
the software.
As users grow, the disk of
your database grows as well.
There is no easy way for
you to extend your disk
space for your database, and
there is no managed re-replica
for you at the database, there,
in previous architecture.
To separate the read and write
operation for your database.
This separation can
also reduce the overhead
of the master database.
So with the managed
service Cloud SQL,
it helps you to smoothly
upgrade your database
in the Maintenance window
that you specified.
When you need to extend
your database disk,
Cloud SQL can increase your disk
when your disk is running out.
And this disk
increase mechanism,
it doesn't affect
your database--
or you don't need to stop
you database service.
You can just
increase on the fly.
And also, Cloud SQL
can automatically
increase your disk when your
disk space is running out.
And you can also
define the threshold
that you want to increase or
trigger this automatic disk
space in Mechanism.
Cloud SQL, also, provides
the failover replica
and the re-replica to help you
easily scale your database.
So failover replica gives you
both the re-ability and also
high availability.
This saves you money without
provision or standby instance
not being able to read.
And last but not least,
the Cloud SQL periodically
creates a snapshot
of your database
so that you can restore your
database from this managed
backup.
Let's quickly look at
how failover works.
In this diagram, you can see
that the primary instance can
be accessed via IP address
Y, and we have the failover
replica, which can
also be read via IP
address Z. And per region,
additional one, re-replica,
for the read-only
work load, and it
can be accessed
via IP address X.
So every second the
primary instance
will send the heartbeat signal.
If multiple heartbeat
signals are not detecting,
the failover mechanism
is initiated.
The failover mechanism
will be also triggered
when the primary zone
experiences failure.
When a failover is
initiated, Cloud SQL
waits for the failover
replica to catch up
to the primary instance states.
The amount of the
time this state text
is highly affected by
the replication lag.
So here is the final
state after the failover.
The failover replica is promoted
to the primary instance row.
The primary instance
name and IP address
are moved to the old
failover replica.
So the application reconnects
to the primary instance
without changing its original
database connection stream
because the primary instance
IP address moved automatically
to the old failover replica.
So another point
that Helen mentioned
at the beginning
of this stage, is
to use Cashe to route the
read and write traffic
from database to the cache.
Memorystore for Redis is used
to handle fast read and write
operations.
You can keep your frequent
access data in the cache.
Like the frequent access data.
Like the session involved.
You can keep this session
involved in the cache in order
for your application to
access this frequent access
information quickly.
It also provides the low
latency for applications
to access these
frequent access data.
It also significantly
uploads the database loading
from your database.
Memorystore for
Redis also gives you
the ability to increase
your memory on the fly
without stopping
your cache services.
Of course you also
provide a standby mode
to provide high availability
when the primary instance is
done or the zone failure.
Here we add two types of
databases into the solution.
We adapt the fully managed
Relational database service,
Cloud SQL, to easily
create the failover
replica and re-replica.
Memorystore for Redis is also
added between the backend
and database there, in order
to offload the database loading
and to provide the low
latency for application
to access those
frequent access data.
The design, at this stage,
we focus on the service.
Its ability for your
application instead
of managing your service.
Right now, we address
the database issue,
the scalability, and
the high availability
with Cloud SQL and Memorystore.
Back to you, Helen.
HELEN LO: Thank you, Harry.
So with you managing
databases, our application
is now more stable, and
we got to 1 million users.
So my e-commerce
website is getting
very popular, and
the next stage,
we're dealing with
another type of issue.
So looking at my current
architecture right now,
I'm serving my
users globally now.
I have 1 million users.
My users are coming
from Europe and Asia.
So my next step is to create
a global, faster web app.
Looking at the
current architecture,
you can see that everything is
hosted in the US-west2 region,
meaning that it's not
really effectively serving
my customers globally.
So my next step is to
replicate this environment
into another region,
for example, US-east
So I did a little research,
and this is a common approach
that I see.
I had my architecture,
my solution,
on the US-west region, and
I did a replica in US-east,
and I use the DNS policy to
split the traffic evenly.
But for some reason,
what if I wanted to add
new VMs in my US-east region?
What I need to do here is I
need to update my DNS policies.
Another issue that might
occur is with DNS cache
by the client.
So what I do here is,
I can set a lower TTL
value to mitigate this issue.
But what if some of the VMs
are experiencing outages?
How should my DNS
policies adapt to that?
And if I'm adding another region
to my solution, for example,
in Europe, I want to use DNS
geolocation routing, instead.
Meaning that users
from Europe will
be routed through our region.
Users from US-west will be
routed to the US-west region.
But as you can see,
whenever I need
to add a new region
to my solution
or I need to add or
edit the loading,
on my architecture
or my solution,
I have to do a lot of
updates to my DNS policies.
So I'm wondering if
there is a better way
to do this in Google
Cloud Platform?
HARRY LIN: OK.
So while expanding the business
globally is really exciting,
but it also comes with
some difficulties--
like you want to
manage your service
across multiple regions.
So Google Cloud
Global load balancer
is built on top of the
Google Global Network
to spread the traffic of your
users across multiple regions.
You can configure a single, in
this case, IP or Google virtual
IP, VIP, on Google load
balancer without creating
multiple low balance
IP for each region.
This means that you don't need
to manage your DNS policy.
The DNS resolution always point
to the single, in this case,
IP address.
So when your
e-commerce business is
getting popular in
Singapore, for example,
you continue to expand your
service in Singapore region.
So without changing
your DNS policy,
without requiring additional
VIP addresses in new regions,
just one single VIP
across the globe.
You can add your new services
in the Singapore region
into this global server
load balancing service.
Along with the single
IP, global reach,
you can also get the cross
region failover and spillover
mechanism on the
global load balancer.
For example, in
real case, if you
have all of your instances
in the Singapore region
who goes down,
users in Singapore
will continue to
be served by being
redirected to the application
backend in other regions.
Similarly, if your application
backends in the US-west
are overloaded,
the user's traffic
will be mostly handled by
the application backend
service in the US-east.
So the global load
balancer helps
you to re-balance
your traffic and also,
your available resource
capacity in multiple regions,
dynamically.
Along with the
global load balancer,
you can also enable the Cloud
CDN to accelerate your content
delivery to your end users.
User experience can be improved
because your content will
be cached at the local POP
and served to a local user.
It significantly shortens the
response time to your user,
and also, your static
content can be stored
in the Google Cloud Storage.
And this static content can be
served at the CDN local POP.
For those dynamic
or static content
generated by your
server, Google Cloud CDN
can reduce the service loading
to avoid sending every request
back to your backend servers.
Now we can serve user requests
with the Global Load Balancer,
but can we make our
Relation database
accessible across
multiple regions?
But not every issue is--
most databases
today require making
trade offs between
scalability and consistency.
So with Cloud Spanner
you get the best
of the relational
database structure
and also non-relational database
scale with strong consistency
across regions and continents.
Cloud Spanner has
regional deployment
and multi-region deployment.
With multi-region
deployment, it automatically
syncs your data across
multiple regions
so that your service
in each region
can access the local
consistent data.
You can scale out,
expand your capacity
by adding additional
instances on the fly
without stopping
Spanner service.
So finally, this is
our architecture--
to deploy your service
into multiple regions,
to serve global users.
Global load balancer
has a single IP
for users without
managing your DNS policy.
Its cross region spillover
and failover mechanisms
dynamically distribute your user
requests to multiple regions
when your capacity in
its region changes.
Along with Cloud CDN, you route
your users to the closest pop
to accelerate your
content delivery,
and Cloud Spanner gives
you a relational database
with global consistency
and scalability.
With this global service,
expanding your global business
is not difficult anymore.
HELEN LO: Thank you, Harry.
Wow, now we are serving
our customers globally,
and we have up to 10
million users now.
So if we go back, everything
started with a small startup--
one developer, one VM--
and now we have
10 million users.
So definitely, we have a lot
more than just one developer.
Now that we are having different
developers, different teams,
ITs, Admin, Ops, we're
constantly updating our code.
We're constantly
deploying our updates,
which is getting
harder to manage
with the new teams and
many people working
on the same projects,
many developers working
on same projects.
So my next step that I
want to do for my company
is to shift from foreign
monolithic architecture
to a microservices architecture.
So the idea that I have,
is to split engineers
by microservices.
So imagine that I have
five to ten engineers just
working on the recommendation
engine and another five
to ten engineers working
on the backend or another
for frontend.
So this will allow engineers
with similar technical skills
and experiences to
work in the same team.
But the end goal is to
improve my development cycle
and make it easier to
manage each service.
So think of this architecture
as a conventional feature
application.
You have the database--
backend and frontend.
How do I decompose this to a
microservices architecture?
I can decompose
this with looking
at the original application's
services functions.
For example, I can have a
microservice for authentication
and a microservice for frontend
and another for backend.
We can kind of see how
my architecture will
look if it's microservice
architecture,
but how do we manage this
in Google Cloud Platform?
How do we manage the
amount of services
and to manage all the
growth of microservices?
HARRY LIN: So welcome to the
Microservices and the container
world, Helen.
OK.
So it's great to see your team
expand to a multiple functional
team, and also, reconsider,
redeploy, or redesign
your service.
To run and manage a
container with microservices,
there are a few things that
we need to think about.
A container lies in the
application platform,
which can help you focus on
your application development
and deployment, not the
infrastructure management.
For example, this
includes some VM instances
auto-scaling cluster management
or your container service
scaling.
It should be, also,
easy for your team
to get started with it.
And also easy for all to
integrate with your existing
CSCD pipeline.
So Google Kubernetes
Engine, GKE,
fixes almost everything
you need here.
GKE is a managed cybernetic
service on Google Cloud.
It provides the
fundamental features
to help you manage and
deploy your content online
with the service.
For example, for the
auto-scaling cluster,
auto-scaling, it manages
your cluster master note
and your work note, and it can
scale based on your work note
loading.
And also it has the horizontal
pop auto-scaling scaling.
To scale your service based
on the metric you define.
And also to protect your
Google Network cluster.
It provides the role
based access control,
the private cluster, network
policy, different security
features to fortify
your cluster.
So not only is it a
fundamental feature,
it also has some
advanced features
to deploy your services.
Let's take the multi-crosser
Ingress as an example
since your VM based
service is already deployed
across multiple regions.
So you want to deploy
your container lies
and microservices across
multiple regions as well.
For microservice, you will need
to deploy your Ingress cluster
in each region and want
to manage this cluster
service as a whole to
serve your global user.
So the GKE multi-cluster
Ingress feature
is an advanced service
that can achieve this goal.
In this diagram, you can find
the web application service
is deployed into two
clusters which are running
in two different regions.
With GKE multi-cluster
Ingress, it
distributes the user's request
to list to different Kubernetes
cluster in different regions
based on the container's
availability and capacity.
So it has the similar concept
to the Global Load Balancer.
You can base it on your
past services or container
services of availability
and also, the capacity
to dynamically adjust the
request to different regions.
And in addition to the container
orchestration platform,
the CI/CD also
delivers a pipeline,
which is also important for your
development team and operation
team to simultaneously
collaborate together.
On the Google Cloud, the
Cloud Source repository
offers a managed source
control repository service
which can trigger the Cloud
to build a new region based
on the criteria you define.
For example, if you push the
code with the new revision
and it has the
specific text then you
want to trigger somebody
to build a new region.
That's one example.
And you can register your
container in the Cloud register
and integrate with
the spinning curve
for continuous deployment.
When the container
of the new revision
is available in
the Cloud register,
it can trigger a new
Spinnaker deployment pipeline,
and this deployment pipeline
can deploy your service
into the App Engine, the GKE,
or even the Compute Engine.
And after the
deployment, you can
use the Statedriver to
monitor your deployment status
and also, service status.
This completes the cycle of the
[INAUDIBLE] of delivery on GCP,
and it could also
be possible that you
are development or operation
team already has their existing
solution in the CI/CD pipeline.
So one of the unique
values to GCP and the GKE,
as well, is openness.
So Google open source
many Google services
like the TensorFlow, like
Kubernetes, Apache Beam.
Therefore, our managed
service are also
open to smoothly integrate
with this open source project.
In this diagram, you can
see that at each stage
of the delivery
pipeline, you can
use the different
open source projects
to integrate with the
Google managed service.
This gives you the
flexibility to create
[INAUDIBLE] CI/CD pipeline.
So the architecture evolves as
this high level architecture
diagram shows.
The GKE now is managing all the
containerized microservices,
and we create a CI/CD
pipeline to manage
application development,
deployment, and operation.
This development team can
use these CI/CD pipeline
to push their code and build
the new revision package.
Operation team can
deploy a new revision
into the staging or the
production environment
and use the different tools
to monitor your deployment
and the service status.
So, Helen, I think
this architecture
can help you to manage your
containerized Microservices
and the CI/CD pipeline on GCP.
HELEN LO: Thank you, Harry.
So we're at the last stage.
We have 100 million users now.
So in this section,
we're actually
going to discuss something that
we haven't talked about yet.
Data, or in our case, big data.
Imagine that we have 100 million
users on my application now,
and there is a lot of
data to be captured.
So for this section,
I want to see
what kind of services in Google
Cloud can help me with that.
So let's start to think
about what kind of data
can be captured on the
e-commerce website.
From the frontend
or UI perspective,
I can have click stream
or user view history--
how long a user
stays at each page.
From the backend
side, I can look
at items added to a shopping
cart or the order history.
But with all the data
collected, what I really
want is to understand my
users and get the business
insights so that I can
answer questions such as--
I want to create a better
recommendation engine
or I want to understand my user
and do a user segmentation.
So looking back on the data.
I can actually categorize
them in two types--
streaming and batch data.
Streaming data are the
types like, click stream,
that's coming in our real time.
And for batch data, think of
it as logs or database data.
So a lot of these
data are actually
captured on a very large scale.
I'm not really sure how to
do this on Google Cloud.
What kind of services
can help with that?
HARRY LIN: OK.
So wow, 100 million users.
That is amazing.
So with 100 million users, you
can imagine how large a volume
you need to ingest
and the process.
So imagine each click
and the View History
are the streaming data
generated by your user actions,
and also, no matter if he
or she visits your website,
clicks on a popular
item, then you will be
generating one streaming data.
So no need to mention
that how these huge data
volumes will be generated on
like the Black Friday or Cyber
Monday.
So for such tremendous
data, you need
to ingest the Google
Cloud pop up service
could be your best choice.
Cloud pop up service can
scale out automatically
based on you ingested volume.
And also, a guaranteed
at least once
delivered for your
subscriber for you
a further processing afterwards.
And for batch data, you can
already store your assets lock
in the Google Cloud Storage
and some transitional data
it can store in the relational
database like Cloud SQL
or Spanner.
So after it ingests
the streaming data,
the Cloud Dataflow can help
you with processing your data
before you store its data
into your data warehouse.
For example, you may want to
remove some duplicate data,
formalize or normalize
your data set,
and afterwards, you will
store all this normalized data
in the warehouse like BigQuery.
Once you're streaming your data
and also, data is ingested,
pre-processed, and you store
your data into a data analytics
service like BigQuery.
You also have
older data you want
to aggregate or consolidate
into that warehouse.
For example, you may have your
CRM, your customer profile,
your purchase history, and
your inventory information.
All this data you want
to consolidate them
into the BigQuery data
warehouse service,
and afterwards, you can consider
to leverage Google Cloud AI
service.
For example, you may
use the Cloud Machine
in the engine to build up
your own machine and model
to forecast the demand.
Or also, build a recommendation
engine on the TensorFlow model
to recommend some
popular items or to build
a personalized recommendation
engine for your users.
So this is the
final architecture
to incorporate the data
injection and the process
pipeline.
Cloud Pub/Sub ingests
the streaming data
from different sources
like the web server
or from your accessed log.
In both, streaming
data and the batch
data can be pre-processed by
the data flow and aggregate
into the data warehouse
service BigQuery
And your data scientists
and business analysts
can use a holistic view of your
data to extract your customer's
insight from BigQuery.
So Helen, would you like to
conclude our journey from one
user to 100 million users?
HELEN LO: This is a very
exciting architecture.
Starting with our
single VM all the way up
to this social architecture.
So looking back
on our six stages,
we started with a small
startup, just alpha phase,
all the way up to
100 million users.
At stage two, we
decoupled our application.
We made our application
scalable and resilient.
And at stage three, we leveraged
manage database services
like Cloud SQL and
Memorystore to have
a better and stable data layer.
And at stage 4, we wanted
to move our regional service
into a global service.
Global load
balancers, CDNs, cloud
Spanners helped me to deploy
my application globally.
And at stage five, we changed
the way our developers work,
our engineers work.
We moved from a
monolithic architecture
into a microservices
architecture,
and we added the CI/CD
practice into our architecture.
So finally, stage 6, where we
started to collect our user
data with the end goal of
understanding our user behavior
and our business insights.
But I don't want
to think of stage 6
as the end of a cloud journey.
Instead, it is actually the
beginning of a data journey,
and again I'm lost.
I'm not sure where to
start on my data journey.
So Harry, please help me.
HARRY LIN: OK.
So it's exciting to discuss
the next journey, the data
journey on Google Cloud.
But unfortunately, we will need
another session to discuss it.
So don't worry, this
is the last slide
of this break out session.
So back to our Cloud journey.
It's more like rocket
science that at each stage
it has its way to
fail or difficulties
we need to cope with.
So scalability issues, high
availability issues, security
and et cetera.
So at each stage, we have
shown different approaches
to cope with these difficulties,
and this is our Cloud journey
to 100 million users.
It is a tough journey
to get through.
So I hope this journey
is helpful for you
to get ready and launch
your Cloud rocket engine.
So thanks for attending
this breakout session.
It's a pleasure to
talk to you here.
We look forward
to your feedback.
Tell us what you like
and what you don't like,
problems you, have et cetera.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]